do you know why we have cases so much
because that's all we do is test
if we cut our testing down in half
they'd say
well they wouldn't say that but cases
would go down in there
now we have the best test and we are
coming around we're rounding the turn we
have the vaccines we have everything
we're rounding the turn even without the
vaccines we're rounding the turn it's
going to be over
president trump again saying that we are
rounding the corner on coronavirus
despite concerns
as cases rise and most importantly
hospitalizations in several states
more than 83 000 new infections
nationwide on friday
a record one day increase since what we
saw
at 77 000 in july so we are moving in
the wrong direction
the medical professionals tell us trump
ally
and former new jersey governor chris
christie appears to criticize vice
president pence's decision
to keep his campaign on schedule after
five people close to
mr pence tested positive for the virus
the whole getting of the of covet to
begin with
and the not wearing of masks has been a
problem and i've talked about that
over the last couple of weeks and so i
think everybody's got to put the health
of the people they're going to be in
touch with
first you got to keep yourself away from
everybody and i and i'm a little bit
surprised
i want to bring in now white house
deputy communications director brian
morgenstern brian thank you for being on
the program today
my first question for you with all of
these headlines about the novel
coronavirus is
what is the white house and the
president's latest strategy for
attacking this precipitous spike which
again
cases yes we're testing it's the
hospitalizations in places like
wisconsin and texas
where they're running out of icu beds
well harris i appreciate the question
the president's response really has been
historic and a big part of that
has been the coronavirus task force
constantly communicating
with state and local jurisdictions
ensuring that they have everything that
they need on a proactive basis
we've had fema we've had admiral polav
check
making sure that every jurisdiction has
supplies that they have personnel
that they have medications that they
have everything they need
to make sure that the risks of this
virus are much
much lower than they ever have been and
that's the case and it's because of with
operation warp speed
we have treatments coming to market
faster than ever soon we'll have
vaccines coming to market
maybe five times faster than ever and so
people are not dying of this disease
nearly at the rate that they were we
know how to
isolate the vulnerable we know how to
treat people oftentimes on an outpatient
basis
uh and so the risks just aren't what
they used to be we know how to safely
reopen we know how to mitigate and we
know how to treat people
and we have the resources there to do it
thanks to president trump
the task force and operation warp speed
you know i want to follow up and and
this is only based on the science
coronavirus is
you know the same type of virus that
generates the coal we've never had an
effective or any kind of vaccine for
that so we are so hopeful along with you
the president the scientists everybody
that we can get there with a form of the
coal on steroids if you will
but when the president says this is
going to vanish what exactly does he
mean
and is that helpful for the american
people well it means harris
that we shouldn't be locking down our
country and it
it's because we have reduced the risks
so much with the treatments that are
coming through the process
we're looking at uh the steroid
dexamethasone we have
the antiviral rem desevere we have
regeneron and eli lily with the
antibodies
and soon the vaccines that will
inoculate not just our vulnerable
populations and health care workers
we hope by the end of the year we look
like we're on track for that
but also uh the general population in
the first half
of 2021 and so we'll be in a place where
the risks will be so low
that we'll really be able to get back to
life as normal and we'll get people back
to work
back to church back to school and we
hope that they can do that now in a safe
way but certainly
really getting back to normal in the
coming months
i want to drill down on the vaccine
maybe some of the conversations that the
president is having with with companies
that you can share with us and
first this though and i've heard you say
kind of in
a different way too than even from what
the president has said he said on
multiple occasions
that a vaccine will be ready very soon
and in the debate
last week claimed it would only be weeks
dr anthony fauci in a
bbc interview agreed but appeared to
kind of clarify those comments let's
watch
we will know whether a vaccine is safe
and effective
by the end of november the beginning of
december the amount of doses that will
be available
in december will not certainly be enough
to vaccinate everybody you'll have to
wait
several months into 2021
so brian i'm curious what the
conversations have been like texturally
that you can maybe share with the
american people
the president these companies doing what
they can what they can to to build out
this vaccine
yeah i appreciate the question harrison
the opportunity to clarify so
what we're looking at uh really within
the next couple of weeks potentially
would be safety
data showing that one or more of these
vaccines that are in phase three trials
could be safe it will be probably
another month where
dr fauci stated you know towards the end
of november we're probably looking at
both safety efficacy data and the safety
data
and then we are mass producing these
vaccines
currently so that by the end of the year
we'll be able to distribute tens of
millions of doses
those probably will go to the high-risk
populations the
senior citizens the elderly the those
who are in a more vulnerable health
state as well as health care workers
those
more likely to be exposed to the virus
but then over the coming months on a
rolling basis
we expect to increase that capacity to
hundreds of millions of doses
so that really anybody who wants a
vaccine will be able to have one
it'll just be a rolling process as we go
through it
real quickly and it's got to be quick i
just heard you say that you're already
mass producing some of them so your
mouse producing things we're not quite
sure yet what we're going to do with
them so you would just toss all those
out
that's right harris what what we've done
with this process and we've gone in
parallel
with the development the safety the data
evaluation process
and the manufacturing process so that if
one is deemed safe and effective it's
ready for distribution
really immediately within 24 hours we
can get doses out on the road
if one is not safe and effective we
would discard that but harris
this is about five times faster than the
next
fastest vaccine has ever been developed
and that's because we have a businessman
president who really threw everything at
this problem
to solve it as quickly as possible
nobody but president trump
would be this innovative this
entrepreneurial and this determined
to get the solution to the american
people
brian morgenstern talking about the
innovation part of it of course the part
that we can't control
is the science and so we will watch to
see what really can happen
brian good to see you today thank you